[Music]
hi everyone thank you so much for
joining us um
in love with animals or are we in the
west
most claim to love animals worldwide
billions are kept as pets
approaching one per human and hundreds
of millions of dollars
are given to animal charities each year
but most people are also quite happy to
eat them
and we've created an 800 billion pound
industry
to deliver animals to our table should
we overcome our hypocrisy
and accept that we don't in fact care
about animals at all
and our aim is simply to use them for
our pleasure
or should we take radical steps to
restructure our diet
and our agribusiness to end our
attachment
to eating animals thank you so much for
joining us to discuss
this uh hot topic i have a wonderful
panel
um unfortunately we couldn't find
cooperative animals to join
to provide their perspective but we have
some fantastic humans
to provide theirs kicking off with peter
singer who is a world-renowned moral
philosopher and founder of the charity
the life you can save peter is known for
his 1975
book animal liberation in which he
argues for veganism
his new book why vegan will be coming
out this month
next up we have christopher belshaw who
is honorary associate
in philosophy at the open university
author of environmental philosophy
annihilation the sense and significance
of death
and his latest book the value and
meaning of life
published this year so some light
reading for some of you there
next up we have peter egan who's a
british uh
actor director and animal rights
activist peter is an ambassador for
bosnian dog rescue saving suffering
strays
and for the animals asia foundation he's
also a patron of all dogs mata
and children animal sanctuary i hope i
pronounced that correctly
yeah and last but certainly not least we
have marianne
siegert who is a journalist and radio
presenter who's worked for the times the
ft
and the independent and has presented a
number of programs on bbc radio
4 she's currently writing a book about
women and authority thank you all so
much for joining us
um so the way this is going to work i'm
going to give everyone an opportunity to
lay out their positions so
um you'll have three minutes to provide
us with your position
um at your pitch as it were so kicking
off if i could ask peter singer
are we hippos critical in the way that
we treat
animals i certainly think we are
hypocritical if we say that we love
animals
because in fact we're extremely
selective
in the animals we love and this is based
purely on whether they appeal to us
whether they're the animals that we want
to have in the home
as companion animals or perhaps in some
cases they're
animals that we like to observe in their
wild habitat but
if while we do this we're eating
pigs and cows and chickens then
we certainly don't love animals as such
because
especially if we're simply buying them
at the supermarket from
the cheapest kind of products we're
buying factory farmed animals
which means that we're complicit in the
utterly miserable lives
that they have had to endure in order to
be turned into
flesh for us to eat or the eggs that
commercially raised industrialized hens
are laying
or the milk that cows are producing
none of these products are produced with
real concern for the animals they're
produced
with simply the bottom line at stake
many years ago ruth harrison said in a
book called
animal machines cruelty is acknowledged
only where profitability
ceases and although there have been some
reforms since then
in terms of legislation unfortunately
that's still
the bottom line if you can do something
to an animal
that makes it more productive makes it
cheaper to produce its product
then that's what's going to be done and
that is certainly not
showing love for animals um christopher
are we hypocritical in the way we treat
animals
well i'm like noah i don't want to put
all animals in the same boat
they're enormously different from each
other in ways relevant to how we
treat them and feel about them people
are different as well
some of us are hypocrites and others are
not nor is love all of the same kind
i might love cats in one way and oysters
in quite another
is the hypocrisy loving some animals and
eating others
or worse loving and eating the same
animal it might appear so
the doggy person enjoys a chicken curry
the farmer loves the lamb but then later
eats the sheep
but i'm not sure that hypocrisy is
really the main concern
the friend of animals might say that if
you love these cute little bunnies you
wouldn't put them on the barbecue
but this friend is likely to say also
and more simply you shouldn't eat them
whether or not you left them suppose
they do say this
is it true well i want to say no it's
not true so then at least want to defend
some forms of
meat eating and at least some among the
meat-eaters
you can eat animals without being a
hypocrite
more important you can eat animals or
some animals without doing anything
wrong
or better nothing wrong so far as these
animals are concerned
maybe we shouldn't eat animals for
health reasons or for the sake of the
environment
maybe also for the sake of other animals
it's bad for the duck if we eat the
ducklings it's bad for cats
they'll be next if we start eating dogs
but i want to say that you can eat the
rabbit without doing
what it is bad for or wrong to the
rabbit
so how's the argument go we'll start
with roadkill
you don't cause an animal's death or
cause it any pain you're neither
wronging
nor harming the animal if you eat it
imagine legs that you shoot and
immediately painlessly kill later to eat
an unsuspecting pigeon does this harm it
well absolutely it does but not all
harms are wrong
we want to live on care about this have
interest in the future most animals
don't want this they don't care they
don't
have these interests for that reason and
i know this is controversial
i want to say it's not bad for them and
we don't wrong them
if we cause them a sudden and painless
death
maybe the painless death is a fantasy so
you're not a great shot
you cause death with some pain are the
reasons not to do this
absolutely there are but these reasons
can be
outweighed you're driving the car
there's some stuff in the road and you
can kill
not painlessly the rabbit or the
children
most of us will kill the rabbit or you
kill the rabbit or the deer
or one rabbit versus the whole warren
fall
but this outweighing isn't
straightforward and you might think that
the slim pleasure of eating
can't justify any pain in killing i want
to disagree but certainly the amount
matters
and there isn't any justification for
the massive
pain involved in factory farming we're
probably all going to agree about that
but it's different where the pain is
smaller
so some pain but we can ask what's the
alternative to this
shortish maybe half a minute shortage
life
with a quickish but pain-free death for
farm animals the alternative is no life
at all
if we don't eat them they don't exist
for wild animals it's a somewhat longer
but still short life with probably a
considerably more
painful death for these animals unlike
many that we love
there's no credible story where they get
a good life
a good long life and a happy death and
that's why it can be okay
to eat them and that's why animal
liberation
is i think sometimes a dodgy term
okay thank you very much for laying out
that position uh peter eagan
are we hypocritical in the way we treat
animals
uh yeah i think so um i certainly was
anyway and i think it's uh
there can be accidental hypocrisy um i
think it's related to that
it's um i always thought that i was a
very compassionate person
and that i loved all animals um but in
fact i discovered
through my journey caring about animals
and loving them as much as i
do that really what i was a a speciesist
what is called as a speciesist um
until i actually had a a a
sort of like thunderbolt moment um when
i realized
that i believe firmly that all animals
have
a right the same right as i have to a
good life
and a comfortable life without any kind
of cruelty
and that happened a long time i've been
rescuing dogs for about um
20 years um and i was a meat eater at
the same time
as rescuing loads of dogs and loving
these dogs and getting that fantastic
serotonin kind of boost whenever i
related to them
and my sense of well-being being with my
dogs was
absolutely unparalleled by anything it
was just absolutely wonderful
and um i i was asked to become
an ambassador to a charity animals asia
by a wonderful woman called joel
robinson and she introduced me to a film
called earthlings and i watched this
film called earthlings
and it's the most devastating um journey
for all animals in terms of being
produced
for the table um and it shocked the life
out of me
and made me realize that in fact i was
in fact a hypocrite
because i hadn't actually spread um
i had very selective compassion and i
hadn't spread it
to all animals i think that
all animals have a part to play on our
planet apart from those that are
selected
for intensive animal farming and
the crazy thing about that is that we
are producing
a situation where the meat that
carnivores are eating is in fact
destroying our planet as we all know
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas